♪ ♪
>> Dagen: A RADICAL LEFT-WING
MOB TARGETING OUR OWN
TUCKER CARLSON, AN ANGRY GROUP
OF CRIMINAL ANTIFA PROTESTERS
SHOWED UP OUTSIDE HIS HOME LAST
NIGHT, CHANTING THREATS AGAINST
HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
THEY VANDALIZE HIS PROPERTY.
TUCKER WASN'T HOME BUT HIS WIFE
WAS.
WHEN THE GROUP STARTED BANGING
ON HIS FRONT DOOR, SHE HID IN
THE PANTRY, CALL 911, THINKING
SHE WAS ABOUT TO BE A VICTIM OF
A HOME INVASION.
D.C. POLICE ARE INVESTIGATING
THE INCIDENT AS A HATE CRIME.
THERE ARE MORE DETAILS IN THIS.
APPARENTLY THERE WAS ONE
PROTESTER CAUGHT MENTIONING A
PIPE BOMB AMONG OTHER DETAILS ON
THE FRONT DOOR BEING BROKEN.
>> Dana: ALL OF US KNOW TUCKER
AND SUSIE, WHO IS ONE OF THE
MOST WONDERFUL WOMEN, TO IMAGINE
IN YOUR MIND'S EYE WHAT IT WAS
LIKE FOR HER, HOW SCARY THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN AND TO HIDE IN
YOUR HOME AND NOT KNOW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
I UNDERSTAND HIS BROTHER WAS
THERE PRETTY QUICKLY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SUCH COWARDS.
IT'S DISTRESSING AND I KNOW THAT
IF IT WAS THE OTHER WAY AROUND,
THAT SOMEBODY ON THE LEFT THAT
HAD A TALK SHOW TO HAVE THIS
HAPPEN TO THEM AT THEIR HOUSE,
TUCKER CARLSON WILL BE THE FIRST
TO DEFEND THEM AND DEFEND THEM
STRONGLY.
I HOPE OTHER PEOPLE WELL.
I WANT TO MENTION FOX NEWS, THE
CEO AND PRESIDENT PUT OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING HOW
REPREHENSIBLE IT WAS.
AND THAT WE AS A NATION HAVE
BECOME FAR TOO INTOLERANT OF
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW AND
THAT RECENT EVENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY CLEARLY HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR A MORE CIVIL,
RESPECTFUL AND INCLUSIVE
NATIONAL CONVERSATION.
THEY SAY ALSO THAT THOSE OF US
IN THE MEDIA AND POLITICS, A
VERY SPECIAL OBLIGATION TO ALL
AMERICANS TO FIND COMMON GROUND.
THAT WAS THERE A STATEMENT
TODAY.
>> Dagen: HOW DO YOU PUT A
STOP TO IT?
>> Greg: I THINK IT WAS
KILMEADE.
HERE'S THE THING, YOU CAN'T TELL
YOUR FOLLOWERS TO CONFRONT
PEOPLE AND GET IN THEIR FACES.
I'M GLAD OTHER TALK SHOW HOSTS
HAVE COME OUT AND SAID THIS IS
BAD.
I THINK ONE WAY TO TAMP DOWN ALL
OF THIS IS FOR EVERYONE TO PUT
POLITICS BACK IN THE BOX WHERE
IT BELONGS.
WE ARE LETTING PEOPLE DICTATE
WHERE POLITICS CAN GO.
RESTAURANTS, ENTERTAINMENT,
MOVIES, TELEVISION.
THE ONE THING IS I CAN SAY THAT
AN JUAN AND I CAN AGREE THAT
POLITICS IS NOT PART OF YOUR
FAMILY.
WITH THE PEOPLE IN THE STREET
THAT WERE AT TUCKER'S HOUSE,
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO LISTEN TO
US BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
LIFE.
THEIR LIFE IS THIS.
THEIR LIFE IS ANTAGONISM.
WE CAN SAY WE HAVE TO TAMP IT
DOWN AND BE CALM.
IT'S GOING TO FALL ON DEAF EARS.
>> Juan: I THINK A LOT OF IT
IS A RAGE.
GET INCITED AND THEY DECIDE
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE IT IN
THEIR OWN HANDS.
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY BE HAVING A
LEGITIMATE ARGUMENT OR DEBATE
HERE ON FOX OR ANY CABLE
STATION, I THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO THEN GET OVERLY
EXCITED AND BECOME THREATENING
AND THINK IT'S LEGITIMATE TO GO
TO SOMEONE'S HOUSE.
HOW ILLEGITIMATE?
HOW INEFFECTIVE?
IT HAS THE CONTRARY EFFECT.
I THINK A GIVES PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT WHATEVER YOU DON'T LIKE
ABOUT WHAT TUCKER IS SAYING, IT
GIVES THEM AMMUNITION TO
REDOUBLE AND FEEL SOME MORAL
SUPERIORITY TO USA PROTESTER.
I THINK IT IS SO KEY THAT OTHER
PEOPLE IN OUR BUSINESS HAVE
RALLIED TO TUCKER'S SIDE.
NOT EVERYONE AGREES WITH TUCKER
BUT KEEP IT IN MIND, DON LEMON,
AN ARKANSAS MAN ARRESTED FOR
DOZENS OF THREATS AGAINST
DON LEMON.
DON LEMON AND TUCKER CARLSON
COULDN'T BE MORE OPPOSITE ON
ISSUES BUT NOW THEY HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON.
COMMON INDECENCY OF PEOPLE
THREATENING YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE
ON TELEVISION MAKING A STATEMEN
STATEMENT.
I GET THIS.
I DON'T LIKE DEATH THREATS, AND
I'VE SEEN THEM FROM BOTH SIDES.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
I DON'T LIKE BEING TROLLED.
I DON'T LIKE BEING ATTACKED, MY
BOOKS, MY WRITING, I CAN'T STAND
IT.
BUT I THINK THIS IS WHERE WE'VE
GONE AS A COUNTRY AND THIS
MOMENT WITH TUCKER IS A MOMENT
THAT WE NEED TO SERIOUSLY ABSORB
AND KNOW THAT THIS IS THE TIME
TO STOP, ESPECIALLY BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE 2020 CYCLE.
>> Jesse: WELL, HILLARY SAID
THE RESISTANCE WOULD STOP BEING
SO UNCIVIL ONCE THEY WON THE
HOUSE.
I GUESS THESE PEOPLE NEVER GOT
THAT MEMO.
THERE'S TWO THINGS GOING ON
HERE.
THE STATE OF ACTIVISM IN AMERICA
TODAY.
THERE IS NO HUGE CIVIL RIGHTS
STRUGGLE.
THERE IS NO DRAFT.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT
THREATENING GOING ON IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
THE ECONOMY IS HUMMING.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
RESISTANCE IN THEIR BLOOD, THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN TO MARCH ON
THE STREETS, WHAT ARE THEY
MERGING FOR?
WHAT ARE THEY MARCHING AGAINST?
>> Greg: AGAINST A TALK SHOW
HOST.
>> Dagen: WE LOVE TUCKER.
VERY TALENTED GUY.
HE'S A TALK SHOW HOST ON CABLE.
HE'S NOT THE LEADER OF A MASS
ARMED RESISTANCE TAKING AWAY
EVERYONE'S RIGHTS.
THE OTHER THING IS WHEN YOU ARE
SURROUNDING SOMEONE'S HOME,
YOU'VE LOST THE INTELLECTUAL
ARGUMENT.
TUCKER CARLSON MAKES PRETTY WELL
THOUGHT OUT INTELLECTUAL
ARGUMENTS ABOUT EMIGRATION,
ABOUT TEARING DOWN MONUMENTS,
ABOUT TRADE, POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
HE DOES IN A THOUGHTFUL WAY.
THE PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH HIM
CAN'T MAKE THE INTELLECTUAL
ARGUMENTS WILL BE WHAT THEY DO,
THEY ARE REDUCED TO SURROUNDING
HIS HOUSE AND CHANTING.
IT IS SO UNCIVILIZED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T LIVE IN THE DARK AGES
WHERE YOU RUSH A HOUSE WITH A
PITCHFORK.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD MAN UP, STOP
BEING SUCH INFANTILE --
>> Dana: THEY SHOULD BE
ARRESTED.
>> Jesse: IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
SOMEONE, THERE'S AVENUES AND
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE YOU CAN BE HEARD.
A >> Dagen: DATA MADE THE
POINT, ARREST THEM, CHARGE THEM
FOR THROW THEM IN PRISON.
BY THE WAY, KILMEADE IS HOSTING
TONIGHT.
>> Greg: I KNOW.